he's Scotland's former first
Alex Salmond denies the 14 charges
against him day 1 of his trial heard
from one of ten women accusers the
former Scottish government official
known as woman aged told how she was
alone with him inside Butte House the
First Minister's official resident it
was June 2014 and they were alone in the
drawing room
she said he sat next to her on the sofa
and pulled her legs over his he was
touching her and kissing her neck and
face she retreated she said feeling she
was being chased like she was in a room
with Muhammad Ali in George Foreman when
she tried to get out of the door he
leaned over her effectively pinning her
against the wall touching her breast and
trying to kiss her while she tried to
wrestle her way out when she did leave
the room she went upstairs to retrieve
her belongings on the way back down he
blocked her exit she said she was frozen
panicking inside and that he then
pounced on her and started removing his
clothes and hers she said mr. Sammon
pushed her back onto a bed and stood
over her naked and aroused before
climbing on top of her Alex Salmond's
accuser said she managed to push him
away get to the left inside boot house
and make her exit she said she felt
hunted humiliated and embarrassed she
said she didn't tell anyone because that
would have been the ultimate humiliation
he has other women she said and I didn't
want to be considered as that coatroom
number three had the alleged incident in
June came after another the previous May
again they were in Butte house he
produced alcohol he'd been given by the
Chinese ambassador and they drank shots
she said he was half cut and put his
hand on her top started to kiss her face
and neck and touch her legs she said she
managed to get up and leave but said she
felt she was having an otherworldly
out-of-body experience
it was like I froze inside she said Alex
Salmond denies the charges against him
in this continuing trial he's launched a
special defence of consent for four of
the charges and alibi for a fifth
James Matthews Sky News